[Laughter]
hey wisecrack Jared here today we're
donning our trench coats as we talk
about what went wrong with the final
installment of the rather tragic Matrix
trilogy The Matrix Revolutions we could
talk about the flat characters unclear
motivations and structural cluster books
but perhaps the most important thing to
address is the fact that well the movie
just doesn't make much sense or to put
it more generously it has some colossal
narrative gaps we basically can't make
sense of the plot without some pretty
massive interpretive leads here are our
top three burning questions one how the
hell does neo have powers outside the
matrix two does neo make his own choices
or is he just a pawn of larger forces
and three is neo supposed to be Jesus
again and how does this religious
imagery fit into the story given how
much thought went into these films it
can't be that the witch house he's just
dropped the narrative ball so royally
right so if the answers don't lie in the
narrative perhaps they lie in the
philosophies that inspired the film's
welcome to this wisecrack Edition on The
Matrix Revolutions what went wrong and
of course spoilers ahead in case you
don't read watch the trilogy every few
weeks here's a recap in the matrix neo
wakes up from a simulated reality to
discover machines control the world and
he is the one prophesized to save humans
from their metal foes digital
ass-kicking ensues in reloaded these
dreams are dashed when we discover that
neo is not special the prophecy was part
of the machines scheme all along and the
film ends with him gaining insane powers
but also in a coma in revolutions neo
wakes from his coma and cooperates with
the machines to beat Agent Smith in a
fight to the death saving humans and
maybe machines from lives of servitude
so how does neo have power in the real
world the only explanation in the film
were given is this tell me how I
separated my mind from my body without
jacking it tell me how I stopped four
sentinels by thinking it tell me just
what the hell is
to me the power of the one extends
beyond this world it reaches from here
all the way back to where it came from
where the source that's what you felt
when you touch those sentinels and then
in the ends of the matrix video game we
get this touched the source and
separated its mine from his body but
these are basically non explanations
since they don't you know actually
explain anything
there are also fan theories maybe
there's a matrix within a matrix or
maybe Neos wirelessly connected to the
source dial-up is very 90s but none of
these are really textually supported
instead we think these mysterious powers
have something to do with French
philosopher Jean Baudrillard in the
matrix the Wachowskis reference
boatyards several times welcome to the
desert the desert of the real
characterizes Bois Gerard's critique of
the postmodern era where meaning and
reality are replaced by Speier
representations for Baudrillard the term
simulacra describes signs that have no
relation to the real but pretend to like
a painting that looks like a Polaroid
photo of a unicorn on Instagram when
these fake copies without originals get
together they form simulations and when
simulations hook up they replace reality
with the virtual the web of media were
plugged into all day
what's worse there's no easy exit from
the virtual you can't tell it isn't real
because who even remembers what reality
is when the virtual becomes more real
than reality itself we enter hyper
reality where technologies and
simulations control meaning not humans
like a desert wasteland reality is
emptied of meaning for humans
the problem is the Wachowski took this a
bit literally they show technology that
controls meaning by literally enslaving
humans meanwhile the real is a literal
desert or more like Mordor Meets
Manhattan and the matrix is not just
simulated ideas and technologies but a
physical network into which humans are
literally plugged even Baudrillard
himself criticized the which housekeys
saying they took the hypothesis of the
virtual for an irrefutable fact
and transformed it into a visible
phantasm but it is precisely that we can
no longer employ categories of the real
in order to discuss the characteristics
of the virtual that's French for they
[ __ ] up for beau Gerard there are no
red pills and blue pills or external
reference points from which you can
distinguish the real from the fake if
you could one could easily choose the
real as neo and others do so laying one
final bit of smack beau Gerard insisted
what would be interesting is to show
what happens when these two worlds
collide it seems to which house he's not
only took boatyards words to heart they
plotted a pretty wild course correction
in the sequels they attempt to merge the
real in the virtual by giving neo powers
in the quote real world we start the
trilogy thinking of neo as real and the
matrix and its programs as fake but as
the matrix revolution seems to imply
we're wrong neo doesn't just plug into
the virtual he can't unplug from it the
virtual is inside of him when he kills
the Sentinels or experiences the train
station in a coma we see a more complex
idea of the virtual that is not the
opposite of the real but a layer of the
real or interwoven and confused with it
that neo can tap into this may also
explain how Smith entered the real world
when Smith clones himself onto Bain the
real becomes virtual the virtual becomes
real and the distinction between mind
and body collapses this idea of the real
world as virtual can also explain why
Denis au can see the world as energy
pulses as if it's virtual here the
Wachowskis borrow from the old archetype
of the blind seer someone who through
seeing less actually understands more
Odin even plucked out his own eye to
gain knowledge although it's probably
not what Bogart had in mind
Neos blindness helps him literally see a
fundamental truth about the relationship
between the real and the virtual namely
that they aren't as separate as he
thought finally Bogart helps explain
what's happening in that train station
the weird limbo space between the real
and the virtual here neo discovers
programs who want to escape the
so-called real world where they're
forced to carry out their programming
and attempt to hide in the matrix
from the perspective of humans the
matrix is a deceptive false space that
steals their agency but for the
program's the matrix is a Liberatore
space where they can be their true
selves if you're a digital entity
maybe the virtual world is the real
world this is perhaps why at the very
end the Oracle is ambiguous in her plea
to the architect what about the others
what others come on say what out
obviously they will be freed is she
referring to the humans or machines
could be both but for the machines
getting out might mean getting in and
for the humans vice-versa this brings us
to the conflict between choice and
determinism which if you remember from
our Matrix Reloaded video they never
shut up about causality action reaction
cause and effect everything begins with
choice no wrong inevitable is literally
the last word neo ever speaks that's
right
right after he says cuz I'm juiced but
wait choose what to keep fighting
something else be clear man and whatever
choice he refers to is it even up to neo
or is he just a product of larger fates
and factors how does this fit in with
the Oracles apparent omniscience is it
some mutation in his programming or
purpose that drives Agent Smith to start
a clone war is it chance or does he
reveal that programs have the capacity
for choice and free will let's see if we
can use some philosophy of freewill
determinism and fatalism to make sense
of this show most of us experience
ourselves as making choices we write
geeky videos on Friday nights because
like neo we choose to and not because we
don't have friends for Aristotle this is
because humans are rational animals our
reason helps us to make choices and
differentiates us from other animals and
technology to call something a choice
one must be able to act otherwise and
not be driven by mere instinct or
programming and most of us probably
agree with David Hume that the ability
to act or not act according to our own
desires and reason is the basis of human
freedom neo Morpheus and the rest of the
gang certainly agree and they are cheats
off because humans are being treated
well like machines with their minds and
bodies totally controlled while plugged
into the matrix they don't seem to have
the capacity to act otherwise and of
course the arc of the whole series bends
toward gaining freedom but of course
it's not that simple
neo and friends don't realize that
freedom of choice is actually part of
the matrix itself in perhaps the most
cryptic conversation in cinema history
the architect reveals earlier versions
of the matrix didn't work because even
though the world was perfect for humans
they were being forced choice
choice but choice is so essential humans
valued it even over perfect happiness
did you know that the first matrix was
designed to be a perfect human world
where none suffered where everyone would
be happy it was a disaster
no one would accept the program entire
crops were lost
the current matrix only works because it
accounts for the human need to choose
albeit a paradoxical choice to give up
their freedom as I was saying she
stumbled upon a solution whereby nearly
99% of all test subjects accepted the
program as long as they were given a
choice even if they were only aware of
the choice at any unconscious level hey
wait doesn't this look similar to
boatyards claim that we prefer and
willingly give up control of meaning to
the virtual why yes it does Jared anyway
this produces anomalies in the heart of
the system neo and his five predecessors
human choice means there are some
aspects of the architects plan that
can't be predicted and turn neo who
chooses to save Trinity instead of
reloading the matrix freewill one
determinism zero but does neo really
make a choice there are several reasons
to wonder first it looks like neo
chooses to give the architects plan a
big middle finger and run off to save
Trinity but for Aristotle and Aquinas
the passions like love anger jealousy or
the Kryptonite of choice and free will
they're no more than animal impulses the
architect also isn't buying it maybe
it's because he doesn't understand
choice you and I may not be able to see
beyond our own choices but that man
can't see past any choice or it's
because he thinks Neos return to Trinity
is just the result of another causal law
love already I can see the chain
reaction the chemical precursors that
signal the onset of an emotion designed
specifically to overwhelm logic and
reason or as a wisecrack favorite puts
it what people call love is just a
chemical reaction that compels animals
to breed it's possible that neo is just
responding to basic evolutionary
programming what the architect refers to
as a chemical reaction Colonel Sanders
and Carnot believes that everything is
mechanistic the matrix fellow programs
and even humans don't have choice but
operate on physical logical and math
medical laws of causation this version
of determinism dates back to ancient
philosophers like Democritus loosest and
others who might confuse for diseases
who began noting the physical world was
not random but governed by strict causal
laws determinist buzzkills that they are
always claimed the appearance of choice
is just part of the system once the
architect notices the human need to at
least feel like they're making choices
even though they'd be plugged in like so
many light brights no matter what he
just adds choice to his determinist
calculations then the whole function of
the one is to control the narrative of
choice and resistance in a way that
suits the machines they're stuck in a
cycle every time you think you're
escaping the system nope
Zion rises the one appears he meets the
architect the one chooses most everyone
dies the matrix reload
die on the one weird conversation choice
death reload rinse and repeat until neo
but even if we buy that it's love with a
capital L not just chemicals that made
him exit door number two or do whatever
he's referring to here there are still
reasons to be suspicious that it was a
genuine choice for medieval theologian
and forty year old virgin Thomas Aquinas
choice is not enough
it's our free will that makes us
sensitive to which goals are best or
most moral and allows us to be held
responsible for our choices is Neos will
free well one very powerful old lady and
something called fatalism makes that
unlikely and fatalism is like
determinism with a heaping spoonful of
the supernatural less focused on
physical laws fatalist claimed events
are destined to occur because the gods
the fates or even our own character and
compulsions directly cause them to and
if by gods they mean a bearded math
program a cookie baking prophet and a
self-replicating Lord Elrond then we're
inclined to agree over the course of the
films the Oracles been very busy she's
the one behind the prophecy and if we're
to believe the prophecy is just a
mekinese entomb ed out the anomaly
and guide him to the source then that
would mean she's tricking neo and his
pals into almost every one of their
decisions even when she pretends it's
his choice
through a fatalist lens it almost seems
like she and the architect are pulling
all the strings and the whole series is
just a game of chess between the two of
them you've been at a very dangerous
game
then again the witch house keys leave us
wondering does the Oracle really make
her own choices or is she just a product
of fate and determinism - by Aristotle
and Aquinas as definitions it seems she
does make choices I made a choice she
makes the choice to save sati and let
agent smith turn her into a clone but
she also says she made these choices to
fulfill her purpose what's your purpose
to unbalance
she also says they had to happen I'm
sure this had to happen I'm sorry I
couldn't be sitting here like you
remember me
but it wasn't meant to be so maybe she
isn't making choices
so if neo isn't making his own choices
and the Oracle might not be either then
is anyone this movie is freaking
impossible maybe agent Smith as his name
suggests is the only real being with
agency in the film when he's killed by
neo he refuses to return to the source
to be destroyed I knew the rules I
understood what I was supposed it's a
choice similar to the one neo makes
right no by his own accounts Smith is a
die-hard fatalist and he doesn't see
this as a matter of will but part of a
grander plan we're not here because
we're here because we are not free there
is no escaping reason no denying purpose
because as we both know without purpose
we would not exist and he's pretty sure
his purpose is still to kill neo
ultimately Agent Smith believes freedom
truth peace and love are just illusions
and fantasies as meaningless as the
matrix itself is it freedom
perhaps peace could it be for love
delusions mr. Anderson vagaries it's
perception temporary constructs of a
feeble human intellect trying
desperately to justify an existence that
is without meaning or purpose and all of
them as artificial as the matrix itself
only programming and fate are real and
because they're not programmed human
lives are empty but just when
determinism and fate appear to have
kicked it out of choice we're reminded
that we'll for freedom peace and love
means something for both humans and
programs I love my doctor very much
I just have never heard a program speak
of love it is a human emotion no it is a
word but matters is the connection the
word implies love is not just an
illusion or some chemical BS it's a
powerful and meaningful connection and
so is freedom or the freedom to do
otherwise sati doesn't have a purpose I
find it to be the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen but where we are from
that is not enough every program that is
created must have a purpose if it does
not it is deleted but her life is still
worth living and she should be free to
live it
neo realizes that just as humans can't
exercise their free will
some programs can't either maybe this is
what makes neo realize that it isn't
just humanity that needs saving from
this war if we really want to talk about
choice
there must be choice for everyone then
again before we can put our neck braces
away we're in for more whiplash because
it's the Oracle who sent sati and her
family here at this exact time for this
revelation about freedom one choice to
help you to guide meal kind of makes it
again seem like she's controlling
everything after
all this and all the films chitchat
about choice it's not clear that neo or
anyone else for that matter actually
makes one if nobody is making choices
that is neo even the real protagonist is
it the Oracle are we even supposed to
care as that there aren't enough
unexplained plot points revolutions ends
with some confusing religious imagery
what exactly is this glowing jacked in
Jesus supposed to show us maybe we can
explain this in terms of choice versus
fate but also faith from the beginning
neo is a quasi religious figure who
helps save humans from their ignorance
and enslavement in the matrix he's
basically straight out of the Gnostic
Gospels which talked about a savior who
is the ultimate guide to the nature of
reality this group of religious mostly
Christian heretics in the early seee
claimed that humans perceive the
material world in darkness sleep night
and blindness and must be saved through
waking knowledge light etc sound
familiar
neo basically spends half the trilogy
just waking up when neo sacrifices
himself he enables true knowledge of
reality and peace between machines and
humans but it's not determinism that
gets him this far it's faith he has
faith in his purpose and in the
possibility of peace even when he
doesn't have a [ __ ] clue what he's
doing I know I'm supposed to go but
beyond that
I don't know even the faith of the other
characters play a big role in turning
the tides of the war yeah so while we
can't explain how neo raises the dead or
how the blind can see that kind of seems
like part of the point maybe the
religious imagery is the last word on
the whole determinism business some
things exist beyond reason clarity or
calculations maybe part of what makes us
human is this capacity for faith in
peace in goodness and something beyond
ourselves
so far we've tried to fill some plot
holes by exploring the Wachowskis
philosophy phase but perhaps the answer
to our question has been lying in a
small detail all along the Oracles
earrings maybe many of the inexplicable
happenings and revolutions are there to
prove some sort of uni and yang II point
that it's not about winning but balance
the philosophy of yin and yang found in
Taoism and Confucianism is present in
the film's not only in jewelry but in
themes like balance cycles and
dichotomies
according to Chinese philosopher Jo dong
Yi Yin represents a dark condensing
force and is associated with metal fire
and the material world yang is
associated with light expanding forces
water earth chi or energy forces and
life flows notice that in revolutions
the real world is full of machines and
bodies and is literally dark and on fire
while the virtual world is of the mind
where things are light and well not on
fire but yin and yang are not
dichotomies they stand for opposite but
connected forces like a light and dark
side of the same hill so why do Asian
Smith and neo both have unexplained
powers and obsess over each other
because they are yin and yang light and
dark sides of the same anomaly what is
he he is you your opposite negative
to be showed at the equation trying to
balance its how about instead of
confusing the real and the virtual Allah
Baudrillard yin and yang help explain
how the real and the virtual are two
sides of the same coin and both are
important for achieving peace between
machines and humans was neo making his
own choices or was he determined by
larger fates like the architect and the
Oracle who are also a bit Union Yankee
we'll never really know but in
Revolutions choice and fate are a bit
yin and yang equally important aspects
of the human experience is the matrix
really a religious allegory bringing
credence to the prophecy or did the
Oracle make the whole thing up to win a
game of wits against the architect again
we'll never know but maybe that's
deliberate both faith and faith are
important aspects of making meaning for
programs and humans and maybe we're
being too meta here but it seems
revolutions even combines eastern and
western philosophy has two important
parts of the philosophical story so to
summarize what went wrong well we've
spent over 20 minutes philosophizing
about these films and still have no idea
what exactly happened but maybe that's
the point the film seems committed to
being beyond sense if they told us
everything or flawlessly implemented
each philosophy wouldn't they just
undermine their whole point that some
things are beyond reasoning calculation
and that's okay
or maybe we're giving the Wachowskis too
much credit either way despite their
flaws we won't be unplugging from these
stories anytime soon
thanks for watching wisecrack we love
making videos for y'all and it's your
support that keeps us going so another
way to support us is by becoming a
patron patrons get immediate access to
exclusive patron only releases including
special podcasts our new video on the
movie it and a sneak peek of our
upcoming wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of mr. robot and another new
thing we're trying out is a podcast
format called wisecrack edition extra
you guys are always asking us about
behind the scenes stuff like what does
the research process look like what is
the writing process look like what does
it take to make these videos well now
I'm holding hour-long conversations with
the writers researchers and directors of
these videos to help you give you guys
extra content if you want to think more
about these properties so if you guys
are matrix philosophy freaks I just
recorded an exclusive interview with the
writer and researcher of this video
you're watching right now you'll get
access to the podcast and everything
else on our patreon page plus we're
working on more exclusives each month
once we reach our big milestone we'll be
able to branch out even further look
there are tons of movies and TV shows
out there that we'd love to cover but
the reality of running a YouTube channel
is that you have to focus on stuff
that's super popular in order to keep
the lights on so by helping us reach our
next milestone we'll be able to make
deeper track videos on topics you guys
request all the time
stuff like whiplash Drive Twin Peaks
Fargo and tons more and as a patron
you'll get exclusive access to these
videos months before anyone else so
click here or use the link in the
description to visit our patreon page
and become a patron and if you're hungry
for more matrix content before you go
check out our matrix playlist here
thanks again for the love y'all peace
you